[Musique]
ces deux américaines se font sermonner
par des policiers à orlando
les deux femmes en question se sont fait
passer pour des grands mères afin d'être
vacciné contre le coc u19
elles n'ont pas l'âge réglementaire de
65 ans mais 34 et 44 ans malgré leurs
déguisements bonnet lunettes et gants
les autorités les ont démasqué mais leur
technique a semble-t-il fonctionné une
première fois puisqu'elle venait toutes
les deux pour leur deuxième injection
geste
laver les mains éviter de s'en passer de
se serrer la main portée hamas y compris
quand on est en voiture et desproges est
bas
on parle de relâchement on regarde pas
que les masques les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui les entrées en réanimation
ni la nouvelle avait déjà fait ce coup
là monsieur c'est du réchauffé ça c'est
aujourd'hui on ne met pas effectué je te
dis c'est amène du frais si tu te fais
un un prend un choc d'antidépresseurs en
intraveineuse vraiment une dose tu vois
très très élevée au bord de la dose
létale
tu peux ne pas ressortir totalement
désespéré par le trip de mac faye et
carlito si tu t'es pas fait cette dose
je pense que ça te pousse quand même à
te [__] en l'air
ce qu'a dit youtube vers dieu droite qui
s'assume - quoi briser là c'est toujours
le droit de vote politiquement à droite
c'est compliqué moi j'ai une chaîne
youtube et je suis un youtube heures de
droite donc d' extrêmement non tout le
monde espère de maintenant nous allons
chez cet atroce qui imagine le général
de gaulle avec carlita 50 entré en
réunion hier à la flotte de 25 à 35 ans
du relaxez vous ne l'auriez vous savez
compter sur moi je sais compter mais
vous manifestez vous ne savez pas parler
et vous n'avez aucune idée ce qu'un
argument parce que depuis tout à l'heure
a annoncé des chiffres là où je vous
demande un navire de causalité c'est pas
que très peu ludique à comprendre non
plus un mois j'ai toujours dans les
meilleurs négociations c'est quoi ces
camps chacun et il n'est pas content
fait souci tout le monde était satisfait
c'est qu' une bonne négociation
d'accords quand ça se termine au dessus
tu es dans le sens et que c'était aussi
un second mandat
non que j'aie vous donner un conseil
et je vous assure que ça conseils
pertinents quand vous n'êtes pas en
plateau essayer de regarder les études
qu'ils ont publiées
vous apprendrez beaucoup de choses et ça
vous à ça nous donnera davantage c'est
un peu moins idiot sur les plateaux
quand vous regardez les décèdent par des
personnes de plus de 80 ans et 60% des
décès par le cos vide donc c'est énorme
le premier ministre a d'ailleurs dit 60%
des décès alors que ces six pour cent
seulement de la population
mais quand vous regardez les décès en
2010 neuf en france est passé la même
chose 60 % de ces décès ont plus de 80
ans donc relativement n'y a rien de
changé il y avait au foot c'est
paradoxal et bien aux etats unis le
département de la santé publique de new
york recommande pour éviter la contagion
de se masturber leur credo vous êtes
votre partenaire sexuel le plus sûr il
ya des endroits où les chats ils
n'aiment pas qu'on leur fasse des grades
grave c'est comme les hommes et andrew
keen tendent l'endroit qu'ils vous tende
très bien on va vraiment passé à
christian parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors
et alors je vais vous montrer les
coulisses de l'exploit quand même
regarder avec la grue regardez regardez
pour vous faire ces images là ce qu'on
est obligé de faire à la télé vous
présente aurélie et nicolas voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]
monsieur
touristes philippe etchebest
c'est votre passion aïe aïe aïe philippe
etchebest et cauchemar en cuisine on est
d'accord
ah bah tant pis c'est maintenant ça
s'appelle touch ou non mais disait
attention
oh là là christian rioux vous avez
failli et a sommé le voisin à terre mais
ça il fallait bien que ça arrive et
c'est très drôle parce que les faits
sont membres ce mannequin qui a qui vont
rien fait comme boussole une chaise
longue et plusieurs ont pas au second
tour
c'est magnifique magnifique 1 1 voilà
vous êtes impressionné personne qui m'a
personne personne pardon c'était de dire
non pas tout à fait y a personne qui
m'impressionne personnes pour moi en
étant vaut tout pareil elle a dit je
peux me dire un mot un cul comme l'arc
de triomphe j ai grandi comme un cul
comme quoi elle a un cul comme la
triumph
oui mais chez nous on dit comme la porte
d'aix
quand vous regarde partir il ya eu une
période de ma vie comme ça où je me
disais que si je contracte impôts donc
tu seras peut-être mieux sans vraiment
savoir si la personne veut regarder
partir sur la longueur était vraiment
vous l'avez loupé un allez juste pour le
plaisir on vous leur maître emmanuel
lacroix grossi ça c est on l'a vu dans
cette petite vidéo c'est vrai alors ils
magazine challenges qui a publié cette
indiscrétion ya quelques jours une chef
de l'état a pris quelques kilos figurez
vous l'elysée a choisi de réagir pour
confirmer cet éco oui emmanuel macron a
pris du poids mais le palais
présidentiel transforme cette prise de
bois en argument politique sur les
photos ses quelques kilos de plus lui
donne de la densité de la maturité
là le gouvernement il serait de faire
sonner chez un truc là et ça fasse pas
ça passe pas par le nénufar d'ailleurs
sa marque un orifice c'est ce qu'on nous
on est là il pourrait peut-être changer
de coiffure parce que dépasser coiffure
ah bon je trouve que cette ambition
éditoriale mans a pris un certain niveau
de bayrou parle de surpoids on peut
parler de sa coiffure vous voyez petite
remarque si le président avait été une
femme n'avait jamais dit ça je te
comprends mais je sais que tu me
comprends pas ce que tu es une fille en
fait mais lui match autisme niveau mille
ne comprend rien